this is a production of cornell
university
great okay
um welcome to
hashtag marigolds
um using social media and having a niche
market
which is what i've been doing i'm
caitlin mathis and um yeah i have the
marigold gardens and it's in ithaca
and uh
let's
go so the marigold gardens
um it's a very small boutique flower
business where i grow exclusively
marigolds i've been working for plenty
of posies
which is a four acre flower farm in
newfield new york for about five years
now
and
two years ago i was struck by a passion
for marigolds out of nowhere
um in 2020 i decided to experiment and
grow 15 varieties
uh just for kicks um but also that
summer i read an article that joan
thorndike had written for the ascfg
newsletter
and
in it she'd put a call out to
east coast growers to start growing
marigolds
because she could not keep up she's in
oregon
and she couldn't keep up with the high
demand uh
and she was getting all kinds of
requests from the east coast so we here
on the east coast need to be growing
marigolds
um
my boss at plenty of posies
told me to get growing and um the next
year i did 40 about 40 varieties of
marigolds for my first official season
as the marigold gardens
and i know we're all getting excited for
the next season
to grow and for all this ice to be done
and
i think
it's looking about 53 varieties for
2022.
um
so what is great about having a niche
market there really is a community for
whatever niche you you find yourself in
i have been
blown away by the marigold community um
there are mentors and customers ready to
exalt whatever that niche is
and i have found so many people through
social media that's the way to find
these people
um actually i think i've met hannah
through social media first oh yeah
um so like i mentioned joan thorndike um
of lemare gardens
i also put everybody's um handle on here
if anyone's interested in following any
of these people
but uh i met joan thorndike um
through social media and then
uh
had written her an email and received
like a
two
page email and response
how to grow things people to contact
just uh
enthusiastically supportive amazing
person um
then i was contacted by
lizza uber herbal which is another
um
exclusively while she grows herbs and
she grows marigolds and she uh focuses
on garlands and she told me
a year before she had done a wedding in
ithaca with for 40 garland she had
shipped them from oregon
so now
she and i are referring each other uh to
each other if i if somebody has an
inquiry on the west coast or somebody's
out here she'll send them to me
um
and then also out of the blue through
social media
um pamela arnosky wrote to me who is
arnosky family farms down in texas
outside of austin
uh arnosky family farms was
one of the first
flower farms to boutique grocery store
sellers in the united states and they
grow a huge amount of marigolds and this
past year they had their first
uh marigold festival
so she wrote to me and she invited me
down there and
uh in true texas fashion like her
messages were full of ain't nobody got
time for that and you gotta plant them
this way and don't waste time with those
soil blockers
um
so it's just been really the community
is there um another great thing about
having a niche market is that you can
feel like you're doing one thing
well so if you have a serious passion
and limited resources and you have a lot
of competition um
which is stuff that we all do
it's so helpful for your business's
health and
your own mental resilience to have
a niche
um
just to know that you are doing one
thing well uh
or you can have a niche within a niche
or a super niche if that's something um
i think that my super niche is going to
be
growing
a huge variety of marigolds it may not
always be the like
strongest stem
marigolds in the business but i think
maybe i can get behind my super niche of
having a lot of variety
um in terms of a niche and social media
social media can
be a lot about
likes and validation that way and it's
great to
have a niche where you're creating
something and the pressure's off from
having it
have to be universally appealing and
you know
no problem there you're a niche you're
not going to be everyone's cup of tea
um
also having a niche
builds in this idea that this is a
speciality
um and it's invigorating to know that
you're creating something that is
somebody's go-to
for this one specific thing for
fans okay about social media
um so i put the big four
up here there's tick tock instagram
twitter and facebook
um a little bit today i'm i'm going to
be talking about instagram and i'll tell
you why tic tac is
the newest
uh
big social media thing it's a video
based
platform it's very young um
and it's very cool and i don't know if
i'm really that cool
i think i could get behind tick-tock but
maybe i just don't have time
um instagram we'll talk about twitter is
word-based and
facebook is complicated i think facebook
is a little
tired or it's not quite um
it's not quite as hip as it used to be
and i'm finding that most of the people
most of my desired online community
is
through instagram
um
now instagram is a primarily visual
platform which is great for flowers i
does have video capabilities and i can
talk about
i'll talk a little bit about instagram's
push towards video content a little
later
um
but if you're wanting to make videos
it's a little less uh
there's a little less need to go and
learn through tick tock
um and it's easy to do on your phone
make some content and put it out there
uh if anybody is
on instagram and you wanna see
what i'm gonna share
another part of my screen
it's a mobile app so you don't usually
look at it through your computer but
this is my instagram page and my feed
and you can see
rows and rows of marigold content
lots of
orange
um
and let me go back to this
so my handle is at the miracle gardens
if anybody wants to
follow along
okay so um let's talk about content a
bit uh first and foremost who is your
audience and who do you want to connect
with this is the main reason that i'm on
instagram
it's that you'll find that a lot of the
people that you're connecting with are
fellow farmers florists
some of your customers
other creatives or other
um
accounts that have to do with
sustainability or social justice or
local accounts that you want to connect
with and build that community
um and then you have to decide what you
want to convey
i find it's really helpful it's kind of
a marketing thing is to choose a bunch
of words that you want associated with
the kinds of images you're putting out
there so
uh
back when i first started my account i
decided kitschy
beauty energy and celebration would be
my go-to words for this and they're
a little bit reflective of my own style
and they're also
i think marigolds are a little bit like
that anyways
um they have a little kitsch to them
they're an undervalued
flower in my opinion
um
and definitely associated with energy
and
celebration and i think beauty
um
so how frequently do you post before uh
this is definitely a personal preference
i was
scared by a friend who's quite in the
know when she said you're gonna have to
post every day
and you it's really up to you what like
what your level of effort is going to be
how frequently you post um
the key i think is to be consistent like
uh and maybe not constant
uh you don't want somebody to
i would say two posts a day is maximum
and you don't want somebody to be
muting you because they're just like
over saturated with what you're doing
um
and then a variety of photos so i went
to a similar talk by the yukon
cooperative extension
and uh about social media
and yoko takamura from asawaga farms in
connecticut they're a vegetable farm and
they have the most
followers on instagram of any farm in
connecticut uh so she was talking about
uh the kinds of variety that she
includes in their feed of the photos so
people respond really well to
seeing who's farming
seeing our faces
um pets
doggies
works in progress field shots
collaborations
uh points of interest they grow a lot of
varieties from japan and they do a
yearly trip to japan so they always
include their
shots from their travels
and then lots of beauty
and
uh
even if you have
an old phone horrible phone or you feel
like you don't have any
uh artistic instincts there are filters
that you can slap on all those photos
and make them beautiful
just go ahead don't be ashamed just put
a filter on it um
and then also
hashtags
so you can follow hashtags on instagram
which i highly recommend
um and then
if you tag your photos it will increase
your following
i have hashtagged this part of the
presentation
goals
2022 because i do not do this yet
i should do this and i have just been
i just have not all my hashtags have
been puns
and no i i i follow hashtag marigolds i
follow hashtag champa zucchio but
i
will start hashtagging my
account
okay um
another thing to think about is how are
you using the stories function
you can share a
niche adjacent content and use it to
sing the praises of other people's work
um and that really is how
a lot of networking through instagram
happens is by
telling actually saying to somebody i
really like what you're doing
you know it's a
[Music]
a system of reciprocity i think
um so
do reach out to people and let them know
that you like their work do collaborate
if possible
if you lift up each other's accounts
everybody wins a good tag
well somebody will see that they'll
start following you
their their other customer will say oh
yeah i'm gonna start following them
um
some really good advice that i got was
find five creatives whose work you
really admire and then try to
collaborate with them in some kind of
way
and once that happens also
bring it into real life send them
a card send them
a garland
or a you know a t-shirt or some a tea
towel
um
so can you use instagram to sell yes
definitely
um i saw instagram being highly
successful for visual artists and
vintage retailers and i thought this
could work for flowers so if your
product is shippable you can have people
place orders through direct message or
you can use the platform to announce
when something is for sale locally
there's a pickup
happening somewhere
um
okay turning it into
irl so just as an example this picture
here this was like the highlight of my
year um
there is a
wonderful florist named sue mccleary who
i have watched for several years just
create these amazing works um and then
i just shared with her that i
enjoyed what she was doing she saw that
i
made amer i was growing marigolds
and she happens to be a huge marigold
fan so
she asked me if she could place an order
and i said of course and we became
friends
and she ordered 500 blooms from me that
i shipped out there
she lives in detroit
and um it turns out that she
is working on her second book
these marigolds this installation is in
the book
uh
with a tagline that says marigolds by
the marigold gardens um
and now uh yeah and now i'm looking
forward to meeting her
in real life at the slow flower summit
uh this year
and it's just a really good example of
how social media can work out for you
um and then i just wanted to talk real
quick
[Music]
about my niche which is marigolds
um just in case anybody came here for
some real good
marigold content
um
the quick story the origin story about
marigolds is that it was a young aztec
uh
couple
they started friends and then they fell
in love
as they got older and
one of them went off to war and
died and then the sun god transfigured
them into the hummingbird
and the marigold to reconnect them
after death
so that's why the marigolds used a lot
in
dia de los muertos
uh to call
your
loved ones back to you
so around the
uh
1500s
the
portuguese conquistadors
put marigold seeds in their pockets
and ended up going to india and that's
how the marigold
traveled to india
and then from there all over the world
um
and i could talk a long time about
marigolds but i just wanted to also say
that this year
one of the things that i love so much
about the marigold
or like having this niche market is that
i get to push
just how far this one variety can go
so um i made
garlands most of my my sales this year
what whether it regarland's with fresh
and dry it's great to have a product
that doesn't
uh
lose its value it's great fresh then it
you can sell it dry or you can
get super tired of it and toss it in the
compost that's really the whole lifeline
of it
um i did some pop-ups
where i sold bouquets um some confetti
for weddings
um some wearable hat things uh by the
bloom to florists
uh quite a lot for botanical dyeing um
for baked goods marigolds marigolds are
edible
um
and then i did some pick your own and
most of the pick your own was
trades for weeding so somebody would
come out
do a little weeding and i um they could
just take what they wanted
and then i did a little uh trading
locally too i
ended up trading a garland a week to
a local indian restaurant and i got a
meal
every week and that was just
the best trade of my life
um really the dream
so
uh
[Music]
yeah what attracted me to marigolds is
that they're okay
we're robust
and um
so easy to invest in fast to grow i
think it's 54 days from seed to bloom
so fast
uh i really felt like this flower was uh
needed a champion to sing its praises
um
and it has a an amazing ability
to stay
fresh and
vital looking out of water for days
um which i don't know any other
flower that does that
um
it's low investment cost
and i love their connection to energetic
and joyous
celebrations and movement
um through life's different trials
there's plenty to explore with marigolds
and to celebrate and share via social
media
any questions
we've kind of run out of time on this
one so we'll we'll hold any questions i
haven't gotten any in the chat so we'll
hold if we get any people
feel free to put them in the chat and at
the end of the session if we have time
we will we'll do some more questions
then thanks caitlin that was great and
i'm dying for spring now
awesome
so if you'll stop sharing we'll get
hannah on
all right so
um hannah volpe
foxy floor is my business uh i
love my hair goals i just want to say
love caitlyn's whole style everything
she brings it's so great
you make instagram so much fun and yeah
i just love following you and i love
being part of the flower community with
you seriously
so um
this i wanted to do a presentation about
soil as the soul of your garden so i'm
going to talk a lot about you know
obviously the the
science of soil but there's so much
about soil that is still so
spiritual and unseen
and it's just the the source where so
much magic happens
um
it's truly
the beginning of everything and the end
of everything as well so just like this
really
magical
amazing topic um and the power of a
resilient garden a strong garden um
any growing area lies in the priority of
healthy soil and understanding that
that's
not something that happens overnight and
in that it's a constant process when you
grow you have to
perform so everything's always changing
and it's the dance between it all
so i didn't really i wanted to just go
through obviously all the basics of what
healthy soil is and just and eat so
this conversation might seem redundant
but um because there's lots of different
angles to take with discussing soil
and environment but
it's really
not bad to be redundant in the different
and the different um lists and criterias
because
it's all it all still is soil is all
connected there's like all these
different parts
um that you want to make sure that
you're understanding but
they're not the same it doesn't have the
same uh power unless you understand them
all together
so um
this is just like some you know more
like personal
uh
personal like
compliments to soil you know it's really
the long game um
it's the it's where like the life cycle
of a plant and all different micro
organisms begin but then it's also where
things decompose
and at the end and give back to the
earth
it's the strength of structure so it
actually holds space and holds
a you know container for things to grow
in but it has this softness where it
also provides like this beautiful
nurturing environment
um it's a home to the to reside but the
heart to fulfill life like there's just
so much expression that comes out of
soil in a garden
uh it's absolutely our planet's life
support system um and i love to make
metaphors of soil
especially to bring in people who don't
have a garden or don't have like a
the mindset around growing uh to try and
you know like catch their um
that maybe they can you know tie in
their own
own uh
niches and their own styles of whatever
their career career is you know to like
help them understand so
you know like mindset um healthy soils
like a healthy mind so your thoughts
lead to emotions which leads to healthy
behaviors just like in soil uh healthy
soil you're not going to be able to get
healthy growth
um without a healthy environment
hannah are you advancing i mean because
it's not advanced so we're still on the
first slide if you've gone to this yeah
yeah okay i can move faster yeah no no i
don't have to move faster we haven't
moved through so i didn't know if you'd
gone to the second slide yet no i'm
still just chatting it up here on the
mic
because i can't read them so i'm sorry
i did it okay
um
and i you know like a healthy body you
know there's just components of being
strong and resilient i always like to
say you know like
help
i'm italian making sauce the the
individual components of a great sauce
are all important but it wouldn't be the
same if they weren't all together you
know same with baking
um
the mechanics of a car you know like
it's all just everything is always
stronger connected so
and i just love this quote charles
kellogg nature has endowed the earth
with glorious wonders and vast resources
that man may use for his own ends
regardless of our taste or our way of
living there are none that present more
variations to tax our imagination than
the soil and certainly none so important
to our ancestors to ourselves and to our
children so it's just
it's a lifelong thing it's not like you
can just set up soil and forget it and
it's like
okay cool
all right next slide
um so
on a very simple level soil is minerals
organic matter water and air right and
then there's different ratios healthy
soil is sustained productivity so
knowing that it's always going to be
evolving and you always have to be
paying attention
and
that system approach so managing all the
different components to continue to
create a sustained
strong environment
and
soil tilth right so managing fertility
balance nutrients and ph support soil
till uh nurture microorganisms so soil
tilt basically being like that
like the thing that you can see the most
clearly right so the suitability of
raising a crop
i won't go through all the lists because
i feel like i stayed on that first slide
talking about the spiritual soil for too
long
so what makes healthy soil right the
collection of micro
organisms fixing
uh nitrogen
right storing a lot of these
a lot of just nutrients and minerals all
the time these heavy eating
um microorganisms still also decomposing
you know like the organic matters to
help be able to provide food for the
plants and other animals
um
it's a
you know like
the thing about our planet that sets it
aside from other planets in the solar
system
um and it's just this you know robust
living system it's all but like the also
the the timeless you know like patience
and resilience for the long haul
um
there's a you know some people say three
types soil some people say four but like
there's six types of soil clay sandy
silty pd chalky and low meat right and
so understanding your soil whether
you're growing flowers whether you're
growing vegetables whatever it is
understanding your soil is always the
first step um and
i'm gonna do this again now you're still
on the first slide so now i think you
are you actually mean to be farther
along
oh
wait i'm not
it's not advancing
oh at all yeah yeah i'm on like the
sixth side oh okay so let me why don't i
share
um your people oh my screen sharing was
paused oh no
sorry
how did that happen
oh my gosh you guys are just like what
the heck is she referring to
it's loading
technology is a wonderful thing ah
i just sent betsy um a
message like
i'm a farmer not a tech person
i'm reminded of this every day
do you want me to share mine since it
doesn't seem to want to come up there um
start from beginning
because now we're not seeing your slides
at all oh there it says loading
okay now it's the full screen so not
gonna can you advance
boom
yay okay i talked about all this juicy
stuff
um
let me tell these i talked about this
too
boom boom
and let's be here together
so um i just wanted to yeah i meant so
whatever whatever you're growing you
know you still have to get to know the
type of soil and even within each genre
whatever you're going there's always
going to be like preferences right so
whatever you know it's like just
different types of um personalities
right the plants desire so
um what the more you get to know your
soil through samples uh and tests and
just feeling it and growing it and
spending time with your soil the more
you can understand
you know how to
amend it shift the environment and
adapt
so i just i really like to share this
one because it's like you know every
every
there's just a blend it's not like you
can just
most the time right exist in solely one
type of soil
and even in different parts of your
garden sometimes you know my my main
flower garden i'm in right now
um
has
it's it's pretty much the same i would
say through the cross across the the
acreage of it but where i was growing
more
recently before that
it was so oh my god it would change like
a lot throughout the whole my all my
annual so yeah you just it's never you
know like it's always good to just
not assume um
yeah so this is a like the more so the
texture of your soil obviously right
clay is like completely different than
sand um and you can improve your soil
health by taking steps to improve the
aggregate stability and penetration
resistance so you want it to be able to
breathe but also um you know hold
structure and and drain okay so reducing
tillage these are like the main things
that you really want to think about if
you need if you're feeling you need to
improve your soil
uh improving drainage that can be uh
like so reducing tillage can mean using
different equipments making sure that
you're only stepping in or
you know implementing tools and things
in soil during certain times i have a
high clay content so i just be really
careful of that because
i can if i
run my tractor over or any equipment or
step in certain places
on the wrong time or like spring is
really hard then i could be very
detrimental to the to that aeration
um
improving drainage you know putting i
have plans to put in some different
drainage trials this year just to help i
mean i see now to this with all today
the snow melts like
you're again reminded pay attention to
where things are pulling and ponding
input or organic matter um
you know like paying attention to that
uh is i mean the more the better more so
now because of all these asian jumping
worms
um
managing nutrients and ph so
getting tests um through your local
resource
free of toxin so knowing the history of
your site can really help with that too
if you're unsure if you have an
implemented toxins
uh and then cover cropping is
is is the most like
uh effective i'll say for like a for
for one step that does so much cover
cropping is amazing for that uh but you
really have to understand cover cropping
if you're
like in a limited season time uh
depending on what you're trying to do so
annual verse perennial
the the you know some cover crops you
can mow and then just basically plant
right into them some cover crops you you
have to absolutely not let go to seed so
understanding your season and choosing
the right cover crop is huge or then
you're being a detriment
uh and then so this is another another
criteria they'll call like you know
uh the factors of your soil health too
so
soil armor which we just like yeah that
structural um
integrity uh minimizing soil disturbance
like we were saying before and that can
even that again can be like
you know driving on your soil or it
could be putting your garden that this
picture is a garden that's got crazy
wind you know so
having different type of protective
measures around your garden if you're in
a really windy location right is huge or
making sure you're not planting an area
where you know has major runoff right
plant diversity having a lot of
different types of um
marigolds
continual live plant roots so
like trying not to have naked soil or
bare soil
and livestock integration which is
awesome
also something you want to manage though
this is a just me with my in the
beginning of this site last spring
i like to use the bcs it's a smaller
piece of equipment because of lesson um
soil compaction
um so yeah it's like your first time
maybe in your site and you're where do i
go where do i start right so your soil
survey is huge um and getting your soil
test
um
and then you can amend accordingly
around like depending on what your
results are around here most people are
always going to be adding lime
and then it's really good too you can
always apply fertilizers
different types of fertilizing through
through water too but it's always better
to
those can be washed out pretty quickly
so the more
applications and amendments you bring
load in there in the spring in the fall
the better
also knowing that you're not you know
i've added i've made the mistake of
adding not cured animal compost and
really thrown off my
the chemical
nature of my soil in a bad way
most annual cut flowers are going to
have similar preferences but again there
might be some really um
you know very specific so just knowing
if you're going to go heavy into one
thing you know just making sure that you
know the types of environments that
they're they're wanting
i mentioned the asian jumping worms i
won't because of time won't go too deep
into that if you don't know about them
check them out
um and then the history of your site so
um
you know just
what was it before was it farmland like
what industrial like what sorts of
things should you uh
you know
pay attention to
this is a picture of my
soil worksheet or some map right so
there's a bunch of different ones um
it's i love it i have it framed
obviously
right
um this was a this is a
beginning of last year so it'll be
exciting to see
you know what um
what
it will be this spring right so percent
organic matter 3.8
pretty good you can get up a little
higher with that um it's not bad right
but
ph is a huge one i
6.2 on the lower side so that just
really you know represents the
capability of the
of the plants to absorb the right stuff
uh soil building
this
is you know again like
this ever evolving dance and knowing
when and the more you get to know your
your site and the types of
pull that the plants you're growing take
so sometimes you know the way you rotate
your garden you might not need to give a
certain
area that much attention but if you you
know are like heavily growing in one
area it's better to um you know think
about giving back like whenever
something is growing you need to
give back so
it's
it's not like building a deck and just
being like oh yeah every
fall i'm gonna stain it and i'm good
it's just a lot as straightforward as
that
um like patience right cover cropping
like i said um
integration of animals uh making sure
like you know
what you're bringing into the site is
appropriate i like chickens because
they're it's pretty safe
you're not gonna burn burn anything
really
over nude that you don't want to have
animal waste that's too uh that's not
cured and like too hot
um
yeah i mentioned all this reduce and
limit compaction living mulch i love
living mulch it's using sort of like
spaces where walkways and to just
continue to grow things and not maybe
just have like
some wood chips sometimes people also
like and that's that's totally fine i
like i don't mind mowing the the
clover so
crop rotation and organic matter
how much time do i have
um
you have about 10 minutes 10 minutes
okay yeah awesome
so um so yeah the soil health like
just recap we i mentioned soil armor
um
minimizing soil disturbance plant
diversity continual um plant and root
and livestock
integration
healthy soil is going to have good
drainage
proper tilth sufficient depth for crop
growth
minimal population of pests and disease
and that's something that you know if a
lot of
growers will could will agree that if
you
the more sustainable your and um
and holistic well-rounded um your soil
is the less pest and disease you're
going to have if you're just constantly
combating something i mean that's
disease are natural pests are natural
but if you're just you know in this
endless really imbalance
then it's probably something to do with
your soil
large population of beneficial insects
sufficient exchangeable nutrient supply
and resilience to adverse conditions
right so this
um
the last couple years have been a really
a strong testament to soil you know like
a couple years no water we were all in
drought you know how
certain types of soil will hold water
stronger
last year
if you didn't have good drainage you
were totally screwed i mean there was
standing water like everywhere even in
places that normally would have strong
strong drainage
and now should i be looking at the chat
or is this okay
awesome i'm mostly posting
thank you oh yeah i meant to do the link
yeah
so when you're considering soil physical
chemical and biological and then
spiritual which i didn't know how far
you guys wanted to get into that realm
but
i
i recommend
always considering the spiritual aspects
of your garden and your soil it's just
just magic like how is there not a
spherical spiritual essence
um
so yeah so the
physical
you want to think about things you know
not just being like
oh you know
uh not everything can change some are
just going to be inherent to your sight
um but but also you know try what you
can drainage you know put in some
low key drainage tiles or maybe you want
to rent a
you have an excavator you want to rent
mini x for the day and really help
drain your site better
um the water availability
right so
um maybe it's redesigning your garden to
be able to receive water differently
a lot of permaculture practices uh soil
or aggregate stability adequate organic
matter so yeah always again inputting um
putting that things that will that will
withstand
soil structure goes right into that um
and compaction so again making sure that
you know when you're moving around your
garden and not
being destructive unknowingly
biological complex network so a lot of
that unseen stuff you can see worms and
different bugs and things like that fit
there's a lot of microorganisms down
there you can't even see but you got to
trust to they're there and to continue
to give them an environment to thrive in
um highly variable and
always changing for sure
um
so organic matter is actually you know
like there's different parts of it so
there's live obviously like your plants
there's dead that's in the process of
decomposing very dead um it's all
important right so
and then chemical uh those nutrients
thinking about the things on your soil
sample
um and again you know most things are
going to happen when i first started
there was never even really cut flowers
as an option to to say like
i'd like to understand my soil test
in
the context in the lens of cut flowers
but now it seems like i've heard way
more of
um
you know highlighting that but i have
always
you know followed regiments around
a lot of the vegetable production annual
at least you know and um
it's felt sufficient so far but it's
like you know
i'm sure there's always specifics and
exceptions
um
this is just example of a
just a little drain i had to do this
spring i had to do a bunch of those
little ones and then i'll fill them in
this this uh i'll have to redo them
obviously but i have a lot of these
little channels around now
um
[Music]
yes
i'll just keep moving
because i talked about those these are
just examples of something like fall bed
i'm sorry the quality looks so bad for
that one yikes uh
ball bed preparation so there's you know
there's a lot of different ways so
um
a lot of people like this the lasagna
layering you know like
the the cardboard that will biodegrade
different layers of compost mulch things
like that this might be example of
something that you're growing in maybe
like in the future future not
necessarily the next year or it could be
straw is another great one uh it helps
you know minimize the effects of the
weathering of whatever your next season
is probably winter right so
especially if it's a year where we don't
have a lot of snow it's really good to
have snow but if you're the wind is
whipping and
just all sorts of stuff all year
that process of thaw and free soft
freeze you know that can do a lot to
your soil so covering it like the tarp
is another great example
it's like vulnerable you know so um
biological talking about organic matter
these are i just wanted these are my
chicken tractors i move around see i
built them the width of my bed
um two beds actually and so
because they the chickens love the
clover so i didn't want to
keep them out of not being able to eat
the rose so i just move these little
tractors around and they get
a bunch of different stuff and that this
is my
um ipm or my my hope for
managing the
asian jumping worms i have in the garden
um
yes and in the chemical way um just
maybe taking another test you know
understanding any inputs you have and
how they can adjust
and then i just want to include some
pictures and or some images i really
liked
um
so just some of these unseen things that
you uh you know there is a lot of other
bugs and things that aren't beneficial
um
but i just love you know there's there's
just so much going on
underneath um and
yeah it's just like it's a whole
obviously a whole thing
um the soil horizons i didn't know how
much i would i should i wanted to maybe
put aside about it but i
i didn't but just to give you a visual
of there's you know like obviously
different layers um so
understanding
the that you know there's
that you don't need to no that's why
people
talk about the difference between you
know like a really deep not having to
plow all the time or taking those really
deep
upheavals
right to sort of keep the the integrity
of
those layers
and then this is just
me as a little youngster and
a couple years ago and just the richness
of
you know the power of what soil can
create for you you know it's just like
the color the plants the food that i
mean
yeah the fiber right it's just it's
it's just such amazing um
foundation for all of life
and
yeah do you have anyone have any
questions i i
i wanted to end a little early just
just in case and if you had questions
about um
you know uh specifically to cut flowers
um
i wanted to leave some
for that too
anyone can put questions in the chat if
they have them
i did have a question earlier that maybe
goes to caitlin
but in terms of um aster yellows and
have you seen aster yellows on your
marigolds
i did put in a resource on astr yellows
it's pretty dramatic if you have it
because it's a it's a virus and so you
get really twisted petals so i'm
guessing that
if you don't say oh yes i have you
probably haven't and that's a good thing
it's a leaf hopper carried disease
no i haven't i've i've grown one variety
that's consistently
um
stumped
and i'm not quite sure like the petals
just
it just doesn't launch at all
um
and i wonder if that's
i'm not quite sure i i tried the same
seed packet two years in a row
yeah
something that's maybe it's just that
but yeah
i have not seen amazing thing about
marigolds is i was gonna put in the chat
that marigolds will take care of those
nematodes for you
um
but they are pretty resilient to
most diseases
good thank you
speaking of diseases we're going to go
now on to giuliana so if you want to
stop sharing hannah we'll move to her
presentation uh well hello everybody i'm
happy to be here today um
as betsy said i'm juliana gonzalez i am
a phd candidate at the cornell plant
pathology and plant microbiology program
um so i was invited very kindly by betsy
and by marjorie daughtry to just come
here and talk a little bit about the
different pathogens that can mess up or
cut flowers
i'm not sure what the different levels
of you know familiarity with this are
you know in the audience so i just
prepared it for like a very general
overview of the different groups of
pathogens that can make flowers sick and
then also a bit of an emphasis on a
couple diseases that um i was told were
you know of importance and interest
right now
so i'm just gonna go through if you have
any questions or but see if you see
anything in the chat that i can clarify
just let me know but otherwise i hope to
not
take the full time so that you can ask
questions either for me or for hannah or
kelly
so um i'm gonna start
uh just as an a very general overview of
cut flower diseases and honestly just
diseases in general for different plants
um we need to understand the different
components that allow for a disease to
happen so i have a picture here of a
very sick and diseased flower
but for that to occur you will have
different situations that need to happen
and that's why we use in plant pathology
this thing here that we call the
triangle the this is triangular the
triangle of disease
which you know originally was designed
and composed of three different things
and then we added time as a fourth
component and i'm gonna explain why is
that important uh and this might seem
very obvious that me telling you you
need a pathogen in your field to get a
disease uh but it's not that obvious
when you stop and think that pathogens
can have different levels of
pathogenicity and they can be either
more or less aggressive and conditions
in your field can actually make them
more or less aggressive so it's
important that that is one of the
components that we have here a pathogen
that is aggressive enough to cause
disease in your crop
then we also need of course a host plant
and in that case we need a host that's
susceptible so it's gonna allow disease
to happen basically and this is
something important also for management
because one of the things that i'm gonna
mention later on is that you need resist
one of the options that you can use is
that you need resistant plants
um to help control disease in your field
so of course in this case for disease to
happen you need a host that is
susceptible and then the last thing
which is very important but sometimes
people dismiss it um is the environment
if you do not have a conducive
environment
for the disease to develop then nothing
will happen even if you have you know an
aggressive pathogen and a susceptible
host you need a good environment for the
situation to go and then as i mentioned
time was included later on as a fourth
component
and it's also important for us in terms
of management and how to handle with
these issues because some things can
happen overnight some things will take
days or weeks
to get to a point that they are you know
bad really bad and we have to manage
them so time is something that we have
to have in mind and understand the
different things that can
affect our specific crop
how fast they develop
how how much time we have actually to
tackle that and then another concept
that we thought was important to bring
today is that not any pathogen can
infect any plant um some pathogens do
have a very broad range of hosts that
they can affect which are you know worse
for us uh because we wouldn't have that
many options of things that we can
switch or change in the field um to
control them but there's other pathogens
that are much more specific to you know
to the host that they affect and in that
case we can for example rotate with a
different crop that's not gonna be
affected but that pathogen that has been
around
and as i said nothing of this will be
important if you don't have the
environmental conditions that lead to
that and that's exactly when where most
of our management strategies come from
of trying to break that environment and
not make it a good environment for the
pathogen to to thrive
um so i'm just as i said i'm gonna go
through the three main groups of
pathogens that affect cut flowers uh the
first one and the biggest one are fungi
uh fungal diseases can cause different
things in the flowers you can have spots
on the leaves or even in the petals here
for example we have a picture of mildew
growing on dahlia and i'm gonna talk
about that in detail at the end
because i know it's a very important one
right now but you can see how the leaves
are basically covered with with the fun
fungal disease and then we can also have
just like spots um like this this one's
here of an anterior nose fungus um we
can also have moldy growth in the plant
so like literally we're gonna see the
fungi growing as for example what
happens with botrytis
this is a marigold actually so i'm gonna
um go back to botrytis in the end as
well
and then we have other groups uh this
one is for example a picture of a rust
that i'm gonna talk about in a minute in
the next slide
and then in management terms very
generally for fungal diseases i'm gonna
break it down a bit but just first so
that we understand what are the things
that we can do for them um the most
important actually is just good
sanitation practices and i know that you
know might sound very obvious for you
all because you're gonna be as clean as
you can in your cups but sometimes we
don't understand why is it important to
do all those things and i think um just
reminding ourselves of what
makes the pathogen have a better
environment and then how we can do to
break that one of the things is just
removing damaged plants because if you
have a plant that has a part of the
plant at least that has already been
affected by the fungal disease then the
fungi will just survive there even if
you leave it in the soil you can think
of that's not gonna make a difference it
can definitely make a difference and
just pass it to your healthy plants um
clean up the materials and the tools and
the things that you use to for example
harvest um and then humidity is going to
be a big one and i'm going to be
repeating that sorry if it sounds
redundant but it's just
very important there are some pathogens
that
need a certain amount of humidity to to
be able to infect um so if that's in our
control then that's definitely one thing
that we have to remember and of course
we always have pesticides
both protectants or just in the surface
or systemic which are the ones that go
inside the plant and kill inside the
plant and i know that's not the ideal
solution but you know in some cases
where it's dramatic
they could be an option
um so just in more detail the three main
groups of fungal diseases that can
affect flowers we have rusts as i
mentioned in the beginning and we
usually see them like this uh this is
one on point batch actually and
i wanted just to break down what are we
seeing in our plants and then what does
that mean so in this case what we're
seeing are usually the spores of the
fungi um you can have in drugs many
different types of spores some actually
have like five different types of for
the whole dc cycle to happen
so that might make it different and
difficult to understand because you can
see different things across the time
of the disease you know
and making your crop sick and it's the
same thing it's just in a different
stage um so that's why we included here
they can have different colors from
orange to red or even brown but they do
look like these raised spots um usually
on the lower part of the leaves
there's many species of rust that can
affect flowers but the most common
species of rust in general the most
common genus sorry is puccinia
and they are usually host specific which
is good in terms that we ex no one to
expect them
but in some cases they can have
reservoirs which means that they can be
on a plant that they're not gonna make
it sick but they're just gonna hang out
there until there's another plant where
they do um you know it works as a host
and they're gonna move there um later on
and then we have fungi pathogens that
cause anthracnose um which is this type
a specific type of leaf spots uh this is
of course just that tissue so we call it
necrotic leaf spots and they usually
generate this circular or concentric um
symptoms this
photo heat is for color to trick them um
in this case gloss protease but you have
different species but that's one of the
most popular uh fungi causing this type
of disease
and again it can have and can affect
different um hosts
and then you have other leaf spots
causing um fungi alternative septoria
maybe you have heard those names in the
past dealing with the situations but
there's usually just spots in the leaves
sometimes in the petals and of course
that's something that you wouldn't want
um on your flowers so
so yeah just important to mention that
what you're seeing is actually the
fungal you know the fungi growing the
fungal growth
um and now to management i'm gonna be
general in this management guidelines
but at the end we'll have different
context of people at cornell that you
can um contact to ask more specific
about your problems right now or in the
future but i just wanted to make a table
that we could just like a general way to
go to and see the differences between
the different groups of pathogens so
when you're thinking of managing a
pathogen in your field
the usual approach is to either control
the current disease which i have here at
number one or control it or prevent it
to going to for example healthy plants
or other crops so that's why i use these
two numbers to differentiate the
different approaches in here um
for us we would
want resistant cultivars usually this
can actually also work as number two as
i mentioned people can use systemic
fungicides or protectants
but it's important that if you use
systemic fungicides you alternate
between them because that helps
not
favor resistance generation as much
also of course as i mentioned is not
usually the ideal way to go uh but what
it is important and it's essential is to
control humidity um rust spores are
gonna move from one plant to the other
very issue very easily with with water
so usually having a controlled
irrigation process and not like
splashing uh things around will be very
important um anthracnose generating
fungi is similar and these spots as well
but for this one um i thought it was
important to include that
since so many things can cause leaf
spots
it's
usually necessary to have a diagnosis of
what you specifically have in your crop
before jumping to use any chemical or
any other approach that's different to
just managing um you know humidity or
sun or that type of thing in in a crop
and then something that seems very easy
or you know maybe obvious uh to think
through it's just a spacing that plants
correctly um
not you know just logically if you have
one plant that is sick and you have one
that's healthy right next to it like
very close together then it will be
easier for a pathogen to move on even if
you're controlling water or humidity
levels but if you have a appropriate
space between them then you can aid you
know make make it harder for the
pathogen to do that
so that's fungal diseases and i'm gonna
go back at the end just to there to
more detailedly go to a couple uh but
again as a general overview the other
group that cause diseases in flowers are
bacteria
bacteria usually cause leaf spots so
that's interesting because you can see
you know you will see a lips but in the
crop and you have to ask yourself does
that look like a fungal disease or does
that look like a bacteria because that
the management would be you know
slightly different for them um so
usually the lift spots of fungal
diseases as i showed you before
are like concentric circles right or
things that you know can break through
across the leaf
um that's because fungi have structures
that allow them to pierce through the
leaf
while bacteria don't so that's why
bacterial leaf spots are usually going
to be angular um this i didn't find out
what disease it was but it looked very
easy to show you in here that it's like
um
the leaf spot will be limited by the
veins of the leaf so but you cannot
really pierce through that easily it's
just gonna be limited by that well fungi
can grow everywhere so you can see it go
through the veins or make circles around
it wouldn't care well bacteria will be
more contained that doesn't mean that
the disease is less harmful it just
means that it will look different um
sometimes it's hard to you know to
identify those differences but just
having in mind that they generally look
different can help um just for an
initial understanding of what's going on
in the crop
um so yeah so you do usually have those
difference in this case we have
santomonas on simeon you can see how
it's still limited by the big um leaf
veins here and then it's hard to tell
you like
examples of bacteria that can cause this
because
really there's many of them
so i'm just gonna say that the two big
or bigger groups of bacteria that can
cause leaf spots and flowers are
pseudomonas and santa monas
that's just because these groups are
very big and they can cause disease in
so many different plants uh so of course
they are also included for cut flowers
um but you know
just to mention that they usually are
related to this
and then something that i thought was
useful and can probably be useful for
example in the field is that you can use
a very simple test to
get an idea if that leaf spot that
you're seeing is fungal or bacterial
aside from looking at how you know how
the the lift foods go which is called
bacterial streaming and for this we
literally just cut through the lesion
let's say that i'm doing it in here i'm
just going to cut like this here
and then put the the leaf on water
if it's a bacterial disease you will
usually see bacteria going out from the
leaf
into the water uh like this
here so that's what we call the
streaming uh if it's a fungal disease
you wouldn't see that so you know
not every there will always obviously be
some exceptions but it's a general
approach that you can do very quickly to
get an idea of what's going on in those
leaves
um in terms of management as i said i'm
just going to add bacterial and then
viruses which are the ones that come
next
humidity and wetness is also important
and in this case um they're going to be
moving the bacteria themselves so
bacteria can travel in drops of water
from a plant to the other plant
previously when we talked about fungi we
were more thinking about the spores or
the canadia which are these structures
the fungal
the fungi used to disseminate in this
case bacteria will be moving themselves
um and they need water even to move on
top of a plant so it's not only from one
plant to the other but if they get to a
plant and they're looking for a way to
get in they will usually use water for
that so it's very important um people
can also use bactericides to treat them
copper is actually something that people
use a lot um lately you know
it has been seen that progressively
there's more and more resistance to
copper especially from the victory of
the pseudomonas group that i was
mentioning um but it's important to
mention anyway because it has been used
for a lot a lot of years and you know as
with
fungal diseases getting a diagnosis is
important so you can do these tricks
that i showed you uh for an initial
approach but then contacting somebody
that can help you um get to really
what's going on could help a lot
and then we have viruses viruses are
interesting because they don't even have
cells they just are
protein and genetic material so i
figured that maybe you have that idea
more clearly now that we have been in a
viral pandemic for two years uh but
basically it's important to mention that
viruses are very different to the other
pathogens they cannot survive on their
own so they cannot survive outside in
the environment for very long they need
to be either inside the host so the
plant in this case or inside a vector
and for bacteria we can talk about you
know
insects nematodes other animals where
the virus can get in it move to a
different plant for example or to a
different crop even and then um generate
disease there
so what we see in the case of viruses or
you know can be different things uh one
i guess the most common are most like
patterns
like this one which actually looks
really beautiful and i know some people
um
like that so like they prefer how the
flowers look when they're diseased but
of course we have to be careful
of not providing
a space where you can just disseminate
to other people's crops but this is
usually what you could see in the leaves
or the flowers
there's also other viruses that can
cause ring spots curly tops in in the
leaves or even stunting this is a
picture of a chrysanthemum that you know
what the one that's
dc's you will see it much smaller than
the other one
um
and what is going on inside when you're
seeing the symptoms is basically the
virus is moving through the different
cells of the plant um and that's where
you're gonna be seeing how it changes
either the petals change color or the
leaves change color um like this
there's some testing available for
certain viruses uh there's companies i'm
in this moment i remember agvia test
strips but i know there's others
that you can purchase if you know or
you're expecting maybe that a certain
virus affects your crop um they're
usually test strips so it's very similar
to what we do with cobit testing for
antigen
you know using antigen tests is similar
but in this case with the plants uh you
can literally just like take a piece of
the dc sleeve uh grind it down and then
put it in contact with the strip which
is going to do the same as the antigen
tests do for us for covet it's just
looking for the proteins of the virus
and telling us if we have it or not
so
you know it's good because you can do it
in the field it's not so expensive but
of course we don't have that for any
single virus everywhere so that's
something to take into account
um and as i mentioned and i'm gonna say
it again in management controlling the
vector is very important
because it's basically the one that's
taking the virus to our flowers so
inside the vector the virus can either
persist or not persist which means that
in some cases let's say that we have an
insect that's feeding on a flower it
takes a virus and then if it's not gonna
persist in it as soon as the insect gets
to another flower the virus will exit
and it will you know um get into that
plant but in the ones that they persist
sometimes they take some time inside the
vector before being released um on a
different flower even if the vector has
been feeding for a while um so depending
on the virus that you have it's
important to have this in mind because
it can also help management understand
the timing of how soon will it transmit
from one flower for example to another
and again when they are inside the
vector they cannot circulate or not
which means some of them need to go
around inside the insect before being
able to infect another plant but others
don't
um and usually vectors as i said we have
insects like aphids trips white flies
which are also a problem on their own
right if we're caring for flowers inside
a greenhouse we're gonna be worried if
we get white flies so
uh i didn't
include in the presentation like tests
in detail just because of time but uh
the people that i'm gonna mention at the
end are also working on this all the
time so you can contact them if you have
that sort of issue
as the same with nematodes which can be
a problem
by themselves and also can take viruses
as an added problem
um so as management as i mentioned we
need to control the vector that's for
sure
um
dispose of infected plants they can
really survive there imagine that
honestly you cannot survive outside a
plant you're gonna hold on to any type
of you know remaining material that you
can find to leave
and then clean everything
tools working space everything oh and
something that i didn't mention before
but it is important honestly for all of
this um is the use of certified plants
or seeds so this is a little bit
different than the resistant varieties
in this case it's just plants that the
company that's selling them to us is you
know guaranteeing but they are free of
the pathogen in this case viruses so as
long you know up to the moment where
they give them to you they should be
free of everything and then you can help
handle them carefully grow them
carefully so that they don't get
infected with anything
um and lastly i'm just gonna you know
quickly go through a few examples of
things that i was told were important
right now in new york um one of them are
mildews so mildews you might remember i
mentioned them in the first slide
because they are um usually
along with fungal tissues
specifically powdery mildew so we have
two types powdery and downy and i'm
gonna show down in a minute but powdery
is uh caused by a you know difficult
different fungi um it usually looks like
powder on the leaves well you can sort
of see it in this one here but i think
the other one will be more specific so
literally you just see powder on the
leaves um
that you know that that you're seeing is
precisely the fungal growth
um
on the upper surface of the leaves and
stems usually also in some cases on the
other side of the leaf you can get
discoloration and that sometimes happens
first so it can also be a way to sort of
get an idea that something's going on um
with the crop
and then this is a picture of one you
know one of the fungi that can cause it
and there are structures that are going
to be growing on top of the leaf in this
case it's a uh structure called a
cleavation but the fact is that it's
just releasing spores and that's just to
remind you that since this is a fungi
you will have to control the spores as
well
and that's one of the main ways it
spreads
they can travel by wind or by water
so both controlling humidity and also
just controlling the space where you're
growing it uh will be important if you
see
you know signals of this in your if your
flowers uh in terms of environment they
are
usually benefited from cool humid nights
and warm dry days so that means that you
know part of spring here would be
um
exactly these um
set of environment that they would need
so that's important to know what moments
of the year this could be more
prevalent in crops than in others and
interestingly they do not require free
water on top of the leaves to grow this
type of mildew of course water is
important for it it can move on the
droplets uh but you know different to
the next one that i'm going to mention
it does require water this one doesn't
so controlling you know water will be
important for transmission but in this
case they don't really require it um
to grow on the leaves
and as i said you know seasonally
situation the situation with this will
change they can survive in leftovers of
your plants over the winter
and even dormant in some cases so that's
something to take into account and then
downey which is the other one i
mentioned this one is not so easy to
identify it's not so evident as the
other one and this one is technically
caused by an oma seat um which are a
group of pathogens that are very similar
to fungi they look similar to fungi they
you have them in the lab and they look
grow very similarly but they are not the
same they have differences in their wall
they have differences in their genetics
so that's why we have them in different
groups um and in this case what you will
usually see is this type of lesions um
more like you know it can change from
light green to yellow
so it can also be confused with just a
leaf spot of a different type um
but you can also get sporulation on the
lower side of the leaf which can you
know aid uh you to understand what is
really going on
um and in this case thick leaves usually
drop from the plants so when they're
thick enough they're just gonna fall
down which is important for management
because we have to remove them in order
for them not to be you know a reservoir
for other uh plants healthy plants to
get sick and this is how they would look
for example in the microscope we'll have
the spores
able to move from one plant to the other
same thing
wind water and then the environment is
very similar but as i said this one does
need water to grow so more important to
control that
and it has a type of old spores that can
get very thick in their wall and that
means they can overwint either by
themselves in the soil um so important
to take care of the soil after you know
a season where you have this disease
going on
and then the last thing i was going to
say is i was told that dahlia
mildundalia actually is a concern right
now and this is usually powdery mildew
so that will be the first one that i
mentioned this is the pathogen that
causes that it looks just like talcum on
it but of course you will prefer to have
healthy dahlias right like this ones
here um
and interestingly this doesn't usually
kill the plants but of course they're
gonna make it less healthy they're gonna
limit the plant's growth um and of
course it's not something that you want
to have in your business and again
same things to do management is very
similar but it is important to monitor
the plans i was going to mention that uh
because sometimes these things can seem
that they like they happen overnight but
they actually have been showing symptoms
before it's just that you have to look
at them very carefully
uh so i just added this here it's the
same thing that i've said so i'm not
gonna pause on it but if anybody wants
these slides later on um betsy can pass
them to you um but again just remember
the differences between both of them oh
and for the powdery one uh it what i
didn't knew this before doing this
presentation but talking with margery
made me realize it's important not to
over fertilize your crop because if you
do then you will get healthy parts of
the plant spread you know more
constantly and for powdery the mildew
will move to these plants much more
easily
that sorry to these parts much more
easily than it will do to maybe older
parts of the plant
and this is the last part uh botrytis
which is also a fungi also was told that
was very important right now so i just
wanted to mention it in detail we
usually call it gray mold because it
exactly looks like that
you can see that this roses here very
thick and it's actually very important
in roses and that's also because it can
affect pre and post harvest which means
that you can see it in your field you
know before harvesting your plants but
then you can also think that everything
is okay you harvest them maybe you sell
them and then at some point during the
process of transportation or even after
they have reached their destination they
start showing symptoms and that's
because the pathogen can be in there
without you know you seeing actually um
something is going on until the
conditions are good enough for it to to
do it and that's bad right because you
wouldn't want that to happen after you
sell them so um usually you will see
irregular
spots on the leaves but then as the
disease progress you will literally see
the fungi growing and it will get really
awful and actually just very powdery in
sense that these pores are gonna be a
lot and they can move easily this is how
they look in the microscope actually
it's a very cute um assembly
but they're very harmful and they can
move very easily um as i said they
spread air water very easily and in this
case water is also needed for them to
germinate so maybe you have you know a
rose that
the
amount of water on it or the humidity
around it is not enough for it to
germinate you sell it and then weeks
later when it is in an environment
that's more humid then it does um
germinate
and same thing uh important to keep
humidity down um leaves from touching
the soil also and then scout for that
tissue and just remove it you can even
put them inside um you know plastic bags
or something to separate the parts that
are deceased from the rest um very
important
so i think i'm close to time and i'm
just gonna stop here because you know we
want to take some questions this is my
cornell email uh my main work at cornell
is not in flowers but i have done a
couple of things with marjorie uh so i
can help a little bit but of course
these people down here marjorie
elizabeth and brian
are gonna be the best contacts that you
can have for this so feel free to email
them and they also asked me to mention
that the cornell guidelines for ipm on
you know greenhouse crops and airbases
ornamentals you can find them in this
link
um
that you know that will contain almost
all of this information and maybe more
much more specific on the different uh
types of things that you can do for for
each uh pathogen or disease that you're
dealing with so just wanted to mention
that and yeah i am happy to answer any
questions if there are any
you did a fantastic job you've got a lot
of information
and also i apologize for mispronouncing
your name it's oh that's
that's fine in spanish it's juliana but
if you translate it is juliana so people
just call me both ways and i'm fine with
that i've only ever seen it written down
so it's nice to meet you also um yeah
that was a fantastic talk and thank you
lots and lots of information there and
these are being recorded so um people
will be able to to listen again and look
again and see the information for all
three of them so there is one question
here about rose rosacea
i i'm not sure what rose rosacea is amy
do you want to say something more
specific
yourself
yes hi it's amy so the rose rosa i think
it's a virus um and we first had it a
few years ago and i just don't know how
one
controls it or wrote it's a rose rosette
um
yeah i guess it is maybe i'm saying it
wrong i could be yeah
it is a virus it is yeah it is pretty
dramatic when it comes in so you'll see
um you get kind of a witch's broom where
all the buds break and then this and the
shoots are kind of reddish and the
flowers yeah
um so i don't know if you have any
information on that
it is a virus
or a yes a virus or a microplasma i
believe yeah i was looking at it here um
but yeah apparently it's one of those
things that there's no um a
straightforward cure you just have to
manage other things
for it but i'm sure that you know we can
look at that into detail right it's
carry-on it's vectored it's one that's
vectored by um an area of iod mite which
are very small
and so they're often hard to see that
you've got them and it is one where most
of the management that i know of they're
finding a little bit of resistance
they're looking for resistance but most
of the management is like pruning off
the parts that show it and bagging them
and taking them away and so that's one
of the things too leona was good about
saying things like okay you know remove
this plant material but also often you
don't want to let it just drop so if you
just let something that's got botrytis
on it drop it will still mature and the
spores will fly around and you'll still
and you'll and it will spread more so
there are times when actually
bagging the part that you're removing is
is really important
um but you're right it's it's relatively
new
um and seems to be spreading you can see
it in wild roses you can see it
pretty much anywhere they've got roses
thank you if i can find another
resource on it but i did just put the
one in for the um
hopefully this is the correct one yeah
for the
greenhouse crops it's interesting we do
not have a specific guidelines for cut
flowers
maybe someday that will happen but the
information is in the greenhouse
guidelines but you do have to check the
labels
to make sure that what your what that
what you're looking at is actually
labeled for cut flowers which new york
state we always have to make sure we
have the crop and the situation so
see are there any other questions the um
caitlin said the breaking disease in the
tulips was the basis of the tulipomania
where you know people would would spend
thousands of dollars
on um
on tulips that had those breaks where
the colors were were not all all solid
um let's see
okay gemma do you have information on
the cca sign in
yeah you can just use if you want cca
credits just um scan the qr code there
i just want to get that up in case
people start logging off that's right
and if you need the dec credits they
need that do they need the link for that
also the new link got it
there you go
all right and i'm going to put in a link
again for the cut flower um
listserv if anyone's interested but we
still have a couple seconds or minutes
anyway for if anyone has questions
thank you it was a really nice mix of
oops that looks odd um i've talked and
and different styles and different
information so um thank you also if
people have topics that they would like
to see in future cut flower sessions at
the producers expo please send those
along you can send them to me in fact i
can put my email address in here if you
want it
you can send them to steve you can send
them to anybody you can find who will
will get them to me
what else can we tell people
if not
thank you all very much to our speakers
and um also to the audience and thank
you for putting information in the chat
and
we'll leave this up a while because
everybody has to get into the decl
lincoln that sometimes takes time
if anyone wants to
unmute and put in information for the
good of the order that'd be great
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu